we are now in our third year grappling
with this pandemic and a recent poll
suggests that fatigue has set in 70 of
americans polled agreed with the
following statement it is time we accept
covid is here to stay and we just need
to get on with our lives of course that
is a complicated statement if you are
particularly vulnerable or already
touched by serious illness for more on
all of this i want to go now to dr
ashish jah who is joining us
he's the dean of brown university's
school of public health uh and he's
going to talk about where we are in this
fight dr john i want to get to your
metaphor of a rainstorm and covet being
that rainstorm and the rain is starting
to taper but before we get into that
metaphor the news about the pfizer
vaccine potentially being available soon
to children under the age of four how
big of a game changer might that be
for our fight
good morning again thanks for having me
here i have a lot of friends who are
parents of young kids kids under five
and for them it's a huge game changer
right it makes an enormous difference
for them in terms of knowing that their
kids are protected and reducing their
anxiety i do expect that authorization
to happen in the next month or so i'm
really looking forward to it i think
it'll help a lot
so the rain metaphor you put out a
series of tweets uh yesterday saying
that cases i.e rainfall are going to be
falling and it may be time as a result
to actually remove some of the mandates
and restrictions uh around masking uh
and other aspects and not having large
indoor gatherings walk us through the
case because i think a lot of americans
are hungry uh to hear the idea that hey
this could be we could be getting back
to normal soon
yeah so look i've found that a lot of
the kind of politicization of these
public health uh measures has been
really puzzling to me i mean when there
is a major storm we don't fight about
whether you should take an umbrella wear
a raincoat but when it stops raining it
turns to a little drizzle or saw
training altogether uh it's fine to put
away your raincoat and that's basically
the analogy i'm using the omicron surge
was a massive thunderstorm massive
bucketing rain it made a lot of sense to
have masks it made a lot of sense to be
doing all testing all the time obviously
i believe everybody should be vaccinated
but what we're seeing is cases come down
they're down about fifty percent from
their peak um where my expectation is in
the next couple of weeks cases are going
to really go down much much further
and at that point it's reasonable with
relatively few infections in the
community to pull back and say indoor
masking requirements are not going to be
there the indoor gathering restrictions
are not going to be there obviously
we'll all still have the protection of
our vaccines
and the one there are two reasons to do
it one is i think people need a reprieve
and the second is if there is a large
surge in the future we want to be able
to go back to people and say hey another
storm coming put on that raincoat put on
those you know
grab your uh you know kind of grab your
rain gear and let's get through the next
storm that's i think how we manage this
virus yep grab your rubber boots i like
the uh analogy dr zha most americans say
they consider this pandemic over when
it's just a mild illness i once i want
to know what's your criteria on when
this pandemic is over for you
yeah well one is i want to get to a
point where hospitals are not getting
filled up to a point where we can't take
care of people with heart attacks and
strokes and appendicitis that we are not
there yet i also want to get to a point
where 2 000 americans are not dying
every day so we are not anywhere near
the end of the pandemic just based on
those metrics alone i agree once it is
up at a point where most for most people
it is a mild illness that will make an
enormous difference you know there isn't
a single point gale where the pandemic
is over the pandemic will fade into the
background and matter less and less the
more we get people immunized and the
more we really begin to manage this
virus effectively
dr jaw final question uh as people can
choose their risk tolerance more and
more
what do you know about so-called one-way
masking meaning most people may choose
not to wear a mask but if you're
particularly compromised you'd wear one
to protect yourself
yeah this is actually a really important
point if you wear a high quality mask a
can 95 or an n95 which are now widely
available um you can protect yourself
under pretty much all circumstances when
i think about when i've been in the
hospital taking care of sick patients
with kovid i'm wearing an n95
and they're not the patients are not
necessarily wearing uh masks and yet i
know that i am protected by that and of
course i'm protected by my vaccine so
for me to compromise people for people
who are worried about getting sick
wearing a high quality mask provides an
enormous amount of protection against
getting infected
hey that's great to know here comes the
sun as far as i'm concerned dr ashish
thank you very much